et pour en parler nous sommes sur ce
plateau avec michel raimbault ancien
ambassadeur de france bonjour monsieur
rimbaud j'aime merci d'être avec nous
aujourd'hui mission plateau adhère t
france alors quel est votre regard tout
simplement sur ce renoncement da
palestine à soumettre la résolution au
vote
c'est très triste mais enfin on peut
comprendre que dix ans l'état de la
cause palestinienne est elle pour
l'instant dans le cadre de la communauté
internationale précisément que c'est
vrai que l'on se demande comment une
majorité s'il y avait même une majorité
qui attire qui étaient rassemblés ce qui
n'est pas le cas apparemment puisqu'on a
retiré même la possibilité de lui aurait
certainement un veto américain
enfin probablement et donc du docteur
durait pas de résolution en fait donc
c'était une peine perdue un petit peu on
dit par ailleurs je ne sais pas si je
peux je crois que c'est vrai que en fait
c'était une résolution qui devait être
présenté en fin par la dalle tunisie
quel seul membre arabe pour l'instant
donc du conseil de sécurité d'un membre
tourner en finlande c'est minime et le
conte dit que là le représentant
tunisien aux nations unies aurait été
limogé parce que probablement je ne sais
mais je suis pas sûr c'est tout sous
toute réserve que probablement parce
qu'il a appris n'a pas au mieux ne pas
référer à ces autorités je dirais
attendu en tunisie avant d'accepter de
présenter cette résolution alors avec la
compagnie de l'indonésie alors bon je
pense sur le fond y'a pas de problème là
mahmoud abbas je passe qui n'excuse pas
ce qu'il va lire dans son discours
d'après midi voilà juste juste qu'est ce
que qu'est ce qu'il peut et sait ce
qu'il peut dire qu'est ce qu'on est
conservé dans la sphère du siècle et
puis dire que valve la transaction du
secteur elle mobilise l'escroquerie du
siècle si je puis dire et il va
certainement dire que
il va menacer de représailles mange pas
il avait dit dans une époque pas très
lointaine bien juste après la signature
de l'accord du de l'accord du siècle
juste au moment de sa présentation par
natanyahou donald trump que il avait
menacé de dissoudre l'autorité
palestinienne sécurité effectivement on
ne sait pas s'il annoncera ça c'était
parce que c'est à peu près la seule
mesure et que gates la tente qu'il
pourrait prendre
sinon pour le reste qu'est ce que voulez
qu'il dise il ya la palestine est
complètement grignoter c'est même plus
un archipel sont des atolls des îlots
qui ceux qui communiquent bientôt de
souterrainement comme des taupes un
réseau de tunnels ne sais pas quoi
et il n'ya plus d'état pas les sites a
plus d'état palestinien possible la
solution à deux états du coup a bel et
bien été enterré en cisjordanie
notamment
alors je ne sais pas ce qu'il peut dire
mahmoud abbas même me disant c'est un
signe d'impuissance se dira jeudi s'il
disait ça jeudi sous l'autorité
palestienne il peut démissionner mais
bon je ça m'étonnerait je crois qu'il
paie un peu les palestiniens prient le
paie le prix de leur division s'est pour
la première fois il ya effectivement un
atout pour moi me mahmoud abbas puisque
tous les toutes les factions
palestiniens tous les partis sans
exception il n'y a pas une seule voie
qui soutiennent accepté l'accord israélo
américain puisqu'il c'est de ça qu'il
s'agit
et donc finalement c'est une force pour
l'autorité palestinienne qui peut à bas
par les s'appuyer sur un consensus en
fait de toutes les forces politiques que
ça soit en cisjordanie et à gaza et
c'est tellement girex qu'un
rapprochement une réconciliation entre
les autorités de cisjordanie et celle de
guêtre l'autorité palestinien de gaza
steilhang le le hamas et les
organisations islamiques hideki qui ont
le pouvoir qui contrôle la cisjordanie
suite à des scrutins démocratiques
d'ailleurs je pense que finalement c'est
ça fait un rapprochement qui est un peu
suspect qui semble fragile et puis haïti
risque de ne pas durer très très
longtemps malheureusement et donc
mahmoud abbas voit pas il a pas beaucoup
de marge de manoeuvre finalement il l'a
très peu de soutien
c'est quand dramatique qu'une de refus
de renault ne renonçait à présenter même
une résolution mais ma vandales
en dix ans elle a aucune chance d'être
d'être d'être adopté ou bien si elle
n'est pas du ciel même s'il ya une
réussi à une majorité suffisante pour
l'adopter
elle ne pourra pas être adoptée quand
même parce qu'il y aura un veto de l'un
des membres permanence par les états
unis
je crois que c'est finalement c'est
quand même quelque chose
une situation de catastrophique mahmoud
abbas a une tâche difficile mais quand
même aussi il doit payer le prix de
réputés l'homme quand une fois les
divisions entre les palestiniens et puis
le prix de tout des hésitations les
tergiversations qu'il a eu ses
faiblesses finalement il est accusé par
beaucoup ce qui est vrai feu suite
lointaines des accords d'oslo
finalement l'autorité palestinienne à
coopérer avec israël sur le plan
sécuritaire c'est même la seule chose
qui était ressorti le positif de la
sphère 20 de positif c'est pas ma fin de
2e du concret du moins et donc ils ont
fait le travail des deux heures de
réprimer au fond les révoltes pops
possible les mouvements de résistance
palestinienne pour le compte d'israël
c'est pas un bilan très très glorieux
faut bien l'admettre
d'ailleurs on ils en paient le prix
politique politiquement alors certains
diplomates ont parlé de certaines
pressions sous couvert d'anonymat est ce
que ces pressions us peut être raison de
ce sera selon vous oh c'est bien
possible
les américains ne croiront ont repris je
pense que je crois que les américains
ont repris 10 ans le texte de l'accord
de paix ils ont supprimé le plein
d'extraits alors on aurait pu croire que
c'était les extraits qui étaient les
plus choquants pour les palestiniens
ils tous les aspects étaient choquants
en fait y compris le principe
bref on aurait pu penser ça tu pourras
télèphe faciliter le passage au
contraire je crois que je crois bien que
ce qu'ils ont enlevés comme passage chez
les passes à tout et tout les résolve
toutes les toutes les mentions des
résolutions du conseil de sécurité aux
nations unies depuis depuis des depuis
des lustres
autrement dit tout ce qui assoit la
légalité internationale de la
revendication palestinienne qui
maintient la continuité de la reine de
la légitimation de la cause
palestinienne selon les normes du droit
international et pauvres droit
international comme il n'existe plus et
rempl l'enlever comme ça et ça n'a
aucune mais aucun comme aucun problème
et je crois qu'ils ont enlevés également
d
et des références à 10 ans je crois bien
y compris au statut de jérusalem fait
tout ce qu'ils pouvaient de tout ce qui
pouvait gêner en fait israël c'est ça ce
qui a été enlevé et on s'en doute
puisque l'accord entre natanyahou et hop
la présentation était d'ailleurs je
pense un espèce de cirque diplomatique
un acte de piraterie sion veut présenter
par deux personnes qui étaient en
difficulté juridique il y en a un c'est
hélas le leem beach man c'était me
trompe c'est toujours vrai jusqu'à
maintenant est depuis natanyahou menacé
pour elle ces accusations de que les
mises en examen de deux contres
corruption et fraude et cetera je pense
que j'ai dû m'en ils ont intérêt à
gagner parce qu'autrement ils hisseront
d'évacuer donc ils auront tort mais je
crois que dans dans la dans la
conjoncture du moment
c'était ridicule cette présentation
c'est scandaleux et on peut dire c'est
vrai que ça n'a pas tellement choqué au
fond malheureusement la communauté
internationale et à commencer par les
pays arabes parce qu'il est comme des
grands responsables là dedans il ya les
palestiniens certainement seller c'est
leur affaire après tout puisqu'ils ont
considéré que le sort du port
palestiniens c'était non pas une
question arabe depuis 1965 mais que
c'était une question du peuple
palestinien bon ils ont assumé leur mal
assumé je dois lire ils ont raté peut
peut-être des occasions de négociations
mais on ne leur a jamais proposé
véritablement des négociations même les
accords d'oslo
je pense que c'était de la frime c'était
une escroquerie donc là maintenant ils
sont dans une situation difficile et il
c'est vrai que l'on a l'impression qu'il
ya une réprobation croissante vis-à-vis
des faits et gestes d'israël parce que
c'est vraiment un femme le comportement
d'israël disons contre les contrôles top
palestiniens c'est vraiment une dé
conduite criminelle des crimes de guerre
uni'sons de façon permanente mais ça ne
suscite pas de réaction politique
finalement je pense merci beaucoup
michel darnaud d'avoir été avec nous sur
ce plateau aujourd'hui pour répondre à
votre question je rappelle que vous êtes
ancien ambassadeur de france merci
beaucoup merci